c'est une décision du Bureau qui a été
prise à l'unanimité les députés du
rassemblement national ont voté pour les
deux députés présents ont voté
pour les députés du groupe et je ne vais
pas citer de nom mais le groupe GDR a
voté pour le groupe écologiste a voté
pour le groupe LR a voté pour le groupe
Renaissance a voté pour le groupe lot a
voté pour le groupe MoDem a voté tout le
monde a voté pour tout le monde a voté
pour j'ai eu deux abstentions pour être
très transparent du groupe la France
insoumise maintenant cette question
effectivement et je comprends les mois
que ça peut susciter chez certains et
cette question a été évoquée cette cette
est-ce que c'est opportun de le faire
maintenant et nous avons convenu que
c'était opportun pour plusieurs raisons
parce que il ne s'agit pas il faut être
très clair il ne s'agit pas d'une hausse
de la rémunération des
parlementaires nous n'aurions jamais
dans le contexte actuel votter une
hausse de la rémunération des
parlementaires notre indemnité
parlementaire nous avons voté à
l'unanimité la hausse du plafond de nos
frais c'est quoi les frais d'un
parlementaire c'est le loyer d'une
permanence qui sert à recevoir des
citoyens c'est les afférente à cette
permanence le chauffage l'électricité et
cetera c'est une voiture et des de
l'essence qu'on met dans cette voiture
pour faire comme un certain député de
lozer entre 40 et 50000 km par an pour
aller voir où qu'il soi dans leur
circonscription les
citoyens c'est ça l'indemnité
parlementaire que nous avons augmenté
c'est celle qui nous permet d'exercer
notre mandat pleinement et de répondre
aux attentes de nos concitoyens quant à
l'exercice de notre
mandat après je vous rappelle et c'est
fondamental qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
somme qu'on nous attribue et que nous
pourrions dépenser tel que nous le
souhaitons c'était peut-être le cas
avant mais ça n'est plus le cas depuis
que la majorité à laquelle j'appartiens
est aux
responsabilités pour ceux qui ont un
petit peu de mémoire en 2017 nous avons
voté la réforme des frais de mandat des
parlementaires et je
peux me rappeler de ce que certains
disaient dans l'hémicycle et nous nous
avons dit les frais et l'enveloppe de
frais ne doit être utilisé que pour les
frais et il ne s'agit pas de nous croire
sur parole il faudra les justifier il
faudra apporter les factures il faudra
tenir une comptabilité et ces factures
cette comptabilité seront contre ôé par
un déontologue qui est ind
dépendant c'est ce que nous avons voté
et je peux vous dire une chose parce que
moi je trouve qu'il faut avoir un peu de
mémoire il y en a aujourd'hui qui
s'agitent sur certains plateaux et eux
ils ne l'ont pas voté ce contrôle des
frais de mandat je vous invite à aller
regarder le scrutin
public donc nous qui l'avons installé
nous qui avons inventé instauré ce
contrôle strict et je peux vous dire
qu'il est strict tous les jours j'ai des
parlementaires qui me disent ah oui mais
non mais ça pinaille un peu sur le coup
de la gerbe et ben oui ça pinaille un
peu sur le coup de la gerbe et ben on
fait pas n'importe quoi parce que c'est
de l'argent public donc ce que nous
avons fait hier c'est que nous avons
augmenté le plafond de l'enveloppe qui
nous est alloué pour des frais mais
c'est pas de l'argent qui nous
appartient moi j'entends un député qui
dit je vais faire le don à tel
organisation de 300 € mais ça ne fait
pas partie des frais qu'il a le droit de
dépenser
l'argent ne lui appartient pas donc il
n'a pas le droit de le faire et moi j'ai
des députés qui en fin de mandat
restitue les relicas et vous savez quoi
en 2017 à la fin du mandat précédent il
y a eu 1 million d'euros de
restitué vous savez combien en 2022
grâce à notre mesure les députés ont
restitué 9 millions d'euros
9 millions d'euros
et je peux vous dire que les députés qui
ne restituent pas l'intégralité des
sommes qu'ils doivent à l'Assemblée
nationale on émet des avis de
recouvrement des sommes on ne les lâche
pas et il payent et pour terminer parce
que je trouve que cette question est
très
importante l'argent qui va servir
éventuellement augmenter le plafond
puisque ce n'est pas de l'argent qui va
forcément être dépensé par les
parlementaires provient
évidemment de nos réserves et nous ne la
finançons pas par une augmentation de la
dotation de l'Assemblée
nationale donc moi je veux bien entendre
tout mais des députés qui dans le secret
de la délibération du bureau vote pour
et qui le lendemain se fendent d'un
communiqué de presse pour regretter leur
vote des députés qui dans l'hémicycle
quand on instaure le contrôle des freins
de mandat s'abstiennent parce que
quand même faut pas aller trop loin qui
maintenant court les plateaux pour venir
dire que ce que nous avons fait c'est
une horreur bien moi c'est donneur de
leçon je leur dis simplement d'être un
petit peu cohérent et surtout et surtout
de ne pas en ayant ce type d'attitude et
ce type de propos dégrader l'institution
que j'ai l'honneur de présider dégrader
le travail de tous ces parlementaires
qui au quotidien œuvre dans l'intérêt
des français reçoivent les citoyens font
des milliers de kilomètres pour aller en
proximité voir chaun d'entre eux c'est
ça la fonction de parlementaire c'est ça
cette belle fonction de parlementaire et
je peux vous dire que je seraiis
toujours au rendez-vous pour défendre
l'intégrité et la moralité du
Parlement les premiers textes que nous
avons adopté en juin et juillet 2022
sont des textes rectificatifs sur le
pouvoir d'achat
non c'est pas les salaires mais
effectivement nous ne sommes pas pour
une indexation automatique des salaires
sur l'inflation c'est une position que
nous assumons mais vous m'excuserez de
ne pas voir le rapport entre
l'indexation des salaires et la hausse
du plafond des frais de mandat que nous
avons voté je ne vois pas le rapport
après non mais je ne vois pardon mais
nous n'avons pas augmenté à nouveau le
pouvoir d'achat des parlementaires c'est
pas le sujet et je peux oui mais c'est
pas ça que vous dites mais c'est ma
réponse et ce que je veux vous dire
c'est quand vous vous êtes salarié
j'imagine vous présenteer des notes de
frais votre entreprise vous rembourse
vos notes de frais et les notes de frais
que vous remboursez ell tient qu'on vous
rembourse elles tiennent compte du prix
de l'essence d'aujourd'hui pas du prix
de l'essence d' y a un an si vous allez
au restaurant on vous dit pas on va
prendre le prix du restaurant d'il y a 6
mois c'est le prix du restaurant
d'aujourd'hui non mais les entreprises
qui remboursent au frais réel rembourse
les salariés au titre des frais qu'ils
ont réellement dépensé et bien nous
c'est la même chose on est remboursé au
titre du loyer qu'on a réellement payé
de la facture de chauffage qu'on a
réellement payé ce sont des frais
professionnels nous ne payons pas nos
maisons avec nous ne payons pas nos nos
frais personnels ce sont des frais
professionnels après faut savoir ce
qu'on veut moi je veux bien qu'on
considère que les parlementaires sont
trop payés qu'ils ne doivent pas avoir
de frais pour exercer leur mandat et
cetera ben je peux vous dire
que demain il n'y aura plus un
parlementaire il y aura plus un citoyen
pour aller mettre un bulletin dans une
hurne nous avons
besoin d'exercer notre mandat pleinement
et les Français n'attendent vous savez
la première qualité que les français
demandent à un parlementaire dans toutes
les études d'opinion vous savez quoi la
proximité alors si moi j'ai pas de
permanence si j'ai pas de voiture pour
aller voir mes citoyens si je suis pas
comme Christophe Blanchet si je loue pas
un camping-car pour aller faire le tour
de ma circo et bien ok je vais être
enfermé au Palais Bourbon et je peux
vous dire que la colère des Français
elle sera beaucoup plus grande